just shot the exterior the master the  scene where I'm introduced  and we watch my first moves towards  seducing deck  Atlas Shrugged is the novel with a messy  and it's integrated into the storyline  and expressed at certain points for the  movie what matters is telling the story  in a way that embodies the ideas  I'm a huge Atlas Shrugged fans so  watching it and seeing it all come to  life was awesome he's really cool seeing  all the characters I've been playing in  my head and seeing them on the screen  saying all the things that I'm had  written it's just the truth  I had to grow a bit personally I had to  learn that interior or to make it  help naked  I thought would be embraced by both of  the material and people were foreign to  you